let's write an arithmetic sequence in
general terms
arithmetic
sequence
so we can start with some number
a and then we can keep adding d to it
and we that number that we keep adding
which could be a positive or negative
number we call our common difference so
the second term in our sequence will be
a plus d
the third term in our sequence will be a
plus 2d so we keep adding z all the way
to the nth term in our sequence and you
already see here that in our first term
we added z we added d zero times our
second term we added d
once in our third term we added d twice
so you see whatever the index of the
term is we're adding the one less than
that many times so if we go all the way
if we were to go to the all way to the
nth term we're going to add d 1 less
than n times so it's going to be n
minus 1 times d
fair enough and let me write that this
is this right over here is our nth term
now what i want to do is think about
what the sum of this arithmetic sequence
would be and the sum of an arithmetic
sequence we call an arithmetic series
so let me write that in yellow the arith
that's not yellow
so let me color changing is sometimes
difficult so arith
arithmetic
sequence sorry arithmetic series is just
the sum of an arithmetic sequence so
let's call my arithmetic series let's
call it s sub n and let's say well it's
just going to be the sum of these terms
it's going to be a
plus
a plus d
plus
a plus 2 d
a plus 2 d
plus all the way
to adding the nth term which is a
plus
n minus 1
times d
now i'm going to do the same trick that
i did when i added when i did the most
basic arithmetic sequence i'm going to
add this to itself but i'm going to swap
the order in which i write this sum so
the s sub n i can write as this but i'm
going to write it in reverse order i'm
going to write the last term first so
the nth term is
a
plus
n minus 1
times d
then the second to last term is going to
be
a plus n minus 2 times d the third to
last is going to be a plus
n minus 3
n minus 3
times d and we're going to go all the
way down to the first term which is just
which is just a now let's add these two
equations we are going to get
on the left hand side s of n plus s sub
n you're going to get 2 times s sub n
it's going to be equal to
well what's the sum what's the sum of
these two first terms right over here
i'm going to have a plus a plus n minus
1 times d so it's going to be 2a
plus
n minus 1
times d
now let's add both of these second terms
so if i were to add both of these second
terms what do i get i'm going to get 2a
plus 2a
and what's d plus n minus 2 times d
so you could view it several ways you
could view this let me write this over
here what is d
plus n minus 2
times d
well this is just the same thing as 1d
plus n minus 2 times d and so you could
just add the coefficients so this is
going to be n minus 2
plus 1 times d which is equal to
n minus 1
times d so this second term also
also becomes
also becomes 2a plus
n minus 1 n minus 1 times d
now let's add the third term i'll do it
in green or the third terms i should say
and i think you're going to see a
pattern here it's 2a
so plus 2a
plus if i have 2 plus n minus 3 of
something if i have n minus 3 of
something and then i add 2 i'm going to
have n minus 1 of that something so plus
n minus 1 times d and you're going to
keep doing that all the way until your
nth pair of terms all the way until you
add these two characters over here which
is just 2a
plus
n minus 1 times d
so you have this 2a plus n minus 1 d
being added over and over and over again
and how many times are you doing that
well you had n
pairs of terms when you were adding
these two equations or in each of them
you had n terms this is the first term
this is the second term this is the
third term all the way to the nth term
so i can rewrite the sum as 2 or the 2
times the sum 2 times s sub n is going
to be n times this quantity it's going
to be n
times
n times 2 a
plus
2a plus n minus 1
n minus 1 times d and then if we want to
solve for sub n you just divide both
sides by 2 and you get s sub n is equal
to and we get ourselves a little bit of
a drum roll here n times two a plus
n minus one
times d
all of that over two
now we've come up with a general formula
just a function of what our first term
is what our common difference is and how
many terms we're adding up and so this
is the generalized sum of an arithmetic
of an arithmetic sequence which we call
an arithmetic series
but now let's ask ourselves this
question this is kind of hard to
remember you know n times 2a plus n
minus 1 times d over 2. but in the last
video when i did a more concrete example
i said well it looks like an arithmetic
sequence it looks like the sum of an
arithmetic sequence could be written as
perhaps could be written as can be
written as the average of the first term
a1 plus a n the average of the first
term and the last term so that's the
average of the first term and the last
term
times the number of terms that you have
so is this actually the case is this
actually the case do these two things do
these two things gel because this is
very easy to remember the average of the
first and the last terms
multiplied by the number of terms you
had it actually makes intuitive sense
because you're just increasing by the
same amount every time so let's just
average the first and or let's just
average the first and the last term
and then multiply times the number of
terms we have
well all we have to do is rewrite this a
little bit to see that it is indeed the
exact same thing as this over here so
all we have to do is break out the a so
let me rewrite it so this
this could be rewritten as s sub n
is equal to n
times
a
a plus
a plus
n minus 1 times d i just broke up this
2a into an a plus a
all of that
all of that
over 2.
and you see based on how we defined this
thing our first term a1 is a a1 is a
and then our last term a sub n
is a plus n minus 1 times d
so
this whole business
all of this business right over here all
this business right over here really is
the average
of the
first
and last terms
last terms i got my first term adding it
to my last term dividing it by two and
then i'm multiplying by the number of
terms we have and that's true for any
arithmetic sequence as we've just shown
here